Donald Trump has reportedly suggested
firing impeachment inquiry witnesses who
were working at the White House
effectively what would end their tenure
at the White House and send them back to
where they came from so to speak
typically other departments so as an
example
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
who testified yesterday the way that
this works is that different employees
from different departments are sort of
loaned to the White House for specific
jobs and many of the people who have
been testifying over the last week bill
Taylor for example they are still
working for the government and sometimes
for the Trump administration in some way
even if not in the position they held at
the time of the Ukraine phone call which
their testimony now focuses on on the
one hand Donald Trump has been talking
about let's fire these people on the
other hand he doesn't actually seem to
know that some continue to work for him
in some capacity and it's truly one of
these comedies of errors that seem so
common in the Trump administration Trump
lashed out yesterday for example at
witness Jennifer Williams Williams works
for his vice president Mike Pence saying
she should read the transcripts very
strange attacks on someone that works
for the government and was employed
directly by your vice president and
what's really important to understand is
that some of the witnesses appeared
voluntarily but other witnesses appeared
under subpoena as they said can you
imagine firing someone for responding to
a subpoena in most administration's it
would be unthinkable in this
administration it seems almost to be the
default position to ignore legal
constitutional subpoenas so maybe they
actually think people who respond to
subpoenas as required by the law are
doing something wrong and they deserve
to be fired very different standards
that are applied under the current
administration
another example is once again
yesterday's witness Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander VIN Minh who confirmed a great
portion of the narrative of bribery and
extortion that we've heard so far VIN
Minh is on the National Security Council
sort of on loan from the Defense
Department
the idea that's been floated is to fire
VIN Minh from the
NSC but what about firing him from the
Defense Department if he's truly what
the trumpets are portraying him to be
which is a dual loyal which will get to
not credible whatever
why should he even be allowed to stay at
the Defense Department it doesn't make
sense because none of this makes sense
VIN man's lawyer made it clear that VIN
Minh is on the National Security Council
until next summer whether he will be
allowed to stay we don't know now a
reasonable person would say why would
they do this
this makes them look more guilty this
could count as witness intimidation for
future witnesses who consider appearing
why would they do this
this is how Trump operates he doesn't
realize or doesn't care that these
obstructive actions call more attention
to what he might have done your mistake
in questioning this strategy is
believing that there's a strategy there
is no strategy these are just Trump's
reactions Trump's behavior and his
reflexive reactions and choices make a
lot more sense if you think of him not
as a president but more like a mob boss
then his choices become far more clear
and of course we'll see what happens
we'll see what repercussions there are
for the people who are participating in
the impeachment hearings legal
impeachment hearings individuals who are
showing up including putting themselves
and their families at risk as we will
talk about soon the idea that they are
the problem when they are exposing the
problem is sickening but unfortunately
it goes beyond just job threats and
that's what we need to talk about next
one of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability
to create multiple virtual cards delete
cards freeze and unfreeze cards you can
put a limit on a card so a company won't
be able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below